on va commander laquelle dans cette
famille le sport est une affaire
sérieuse partagé par tous en période de
confinement cela se passe dans le jardin
est sous les ordres des deux grandes
filles qui jouent dans l'une des équipes
féminines majeurs de la région les
sports athlétiques vierzonnais section
rugby option elle a été arrêtée ce pacte
va reprendre malheureusement parce qu'on
sait pas combien de temps ça va durer
donc du coup ça nous permet quand même
nous nous tenir nous visitons vie alors
fait 700 semble non sans courage
3 tous suivent un programme précis
transmis par fichier vidéo est conçu à
vierzon même voilà par rapport aux
exercices de pionner tri pascal et
stephen balula habite à quelques
centaines de mètres de la famille gillet
mais non plus que le truchement de
l'ordinateur pour rester en contact
ils sont éducateur à l'école de rugby
locale et ont inventé un rendez vous
quotidien virtuel pour maintenir le lien
avec l'ensemble du club
j'ai un jeune qui m'a demandé si ma
femme pouvait continuer à leur fournir
des programmes de renforcement
musculaire pendant la durée du
confinement donc bien entendu j'en ai
discuté avec elle et la vie plutôt que
de faire un programme simple ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va faire des montages
vidéo pour que chaque jour les jeunes
reçoivent un programme quotidien et
diversifiée honnêtement ça ça permet je
pense aussi de tenir que ce soit pour
les joueurs mais également pour nous
pour nous donner aussi un objectif même
entendu et puis quand tout sera terminé
on a prévu aussi peut-être de faire un
vrai rendez vous avec un vrai banque est
effectivement échanger tous ces bons
moments autour d'un verre
en attendant la fête tous les
participants se sont donnés un autre
objectif rappeler le défi numéro un du
moment surtout